I have no problem with
each and every one of us our behaviors
what I'm just saying is that if you really want
look at climate change in the face
we need to reduce by 80
of our meat consumption
but it's like the cigarette
the cigarette for a very long time has been
a symbol of virility
a symbol of social positioning
of emancipation
and then to fight against smoking
we had to reverse the image of the cigarette
it's exactly the same thing
finally here we calm down everything will be fine
I assure you
were you surprised
and maybe we can see that yes
by the fact that this debate is gaining so much momentum
that we still talk about it
and still today
week plus one of this controversial sentence
already it is necessary to put the context
I said it in a workshop of the ecologists
where for an hour we talked
with the association l214
who does an absolutely extraordinary job
to alert us to the conditions of breeding
so to ask yourself how to reduce meat
so I said this sentence
I knew when I said the word virility
that obviously some companies attack
but I was not imagining
not that it would be a one week controversy
on the question of virility
what you need to see is how it will fall back down
do we always eat so much meat
is it in the canteens
we serve as much
has there been a profound change